via finance division one work session
first we have a Mr Wallace who is here I
don't believe I've
okay there you are you could
introduce yourself and you'll be
speaking
on the uh
credit limit that we were discussing
last week
credit limit increase
you're all set good morning Mr chair
thank you uh for the record I'm James
key Wallace I'm the executive director
of the state of New Hampshire's business
Finance Authority uh thank you for
having me here today I understand there
was some brief discussion last week
about the section in hb2 to increase the
bfa's contingent credit limit from its
current limit of 115 million to 200
million so I wanted to make myself
available today both to talk a little
bit about what the BFA what we do what
we don't a little bit about the request
and why it's important for us and then
of course you know trying to answer any
questions that the committee may have
um
so if I could I'd love to just explain
briefly who the BFA is
um and why this is important to us
all right
um so the New Hampshire BFA is has been
around for a little over 30 years we
were created
um on the tales of a banking crisis
um when Banks were going out of business
were left and right in the state during
the Savings and Loan crisis late 80s
early 90s uh Governor Judd Greg created
the BFA with the assistance of the
legislature at the time and our mission
really is to help ensure that companies
in New Hampshire who want to attract
financing and can afford to repay that
financing are able to get that financing
from their bank so they can grow and
they can make jobs
couple
interesting facts about the BFA
um is it has always designed to operate
as a fully self-funding state agency and
never use any state taxpayer dollars and
that's been true the state has
occasionally used us as a conduit to
give grants to groups they want to give
and how to oversee those grants but
we've never
use State taxpayer dollars for our
lending our operations our activities
everything we do has to pay for itself
um we provide a couple of different
Services the thing we're known for the
most is our loan guarantee program it's
used when a company needs a little bit
of help getting across the Finish Line
with their lender a very recent example
of that program is a company known as
Sperry tents Exeter rentals or the legal
name they make and they do tents they
rent tents for outdoor events right
um there was a little something a couple
years ago you know called covid-19 and
you might remember people weren't
allowed to get together for a brief
period of time
um at all and then with certain numbers
and then Etc et cetera and you've got to
imagine if you're an event tent rental
company this sort of it crushed you
right so that was very difficult for
that business in particular
restrictions were lifted later date
again to recover began to do well needed
some financing from their bank and their
Bank said as required by Federal
Regulation show me your last three years
financial statements
they didn't look so great they had all
the reasons in the world why they didn't
look so great but nonetheless the bank
was simply not allowed to make them
alone without some type of credit
enhancement from somebody like the BFA
so we sat we analyzed the company good
company been around a long time went
through a clear
situation that really wasn't there
within their control and now needed help
to get across we helped provide a loan
guarantee for a loan for the company
they're doing great and everything's
going fine
um you know they employ a lot a lot of
people here in New Hampshire so that's
sort of an example of some of what our
loan guarantee programs reviews you know
been used for
other situations we're known for we help
bring BAE Systems to Manchester
they have employed over 800 people now
in Manchester which is a Big Boon for
the city and really for the state and
recently we've done two transactions
with Sig Sauer that have caused them to
help have a facility to produce the new
next-gen machine gun that supports our
armed services so we work with big
employers we work with small employers
um and our products have been used we've
never had the state ever had to cover
one of our guarantees we we require
collateral in every single transaction
that we do
and we're required to establish reserves
to cover any loss to insulate the state
from paying on a guarantee if it were
ever to be required
um we've been very busy in the last
several years it's been eight years
since our limit has been increased it's
happened several times throughout the
history since the 90s
inflation has been very serious
um especially in the constructing of new
building I don't know if you've tried to
get a piece of plywood to replace your
garage recently but it's pretty wild or
you know heck you know I think you know
steel beam
um but long story short you know a 10
million dollar building not that long
ago is a 20 million dollar building now
so it takes us more of our contingent
credit limit to do the same transactions
and at the same time we're also seeing
more requests than we've ever seen so
this is important to us we're actually
getting close to being out of our
contingent credit limit so the request
is Timely
and I'd be happy to take questions
all right for those trying to follow
this it's on page 89 in House Bill 2
Section 281 representative McGuire has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming so
um let's use the temp company as an
example
let's say they fail right and and go
bankrupt what would happen you would get
position possession of the tents and
sell them and to pay yourself back or
how does that work almost yes uh thank
you representative it would the bank
actually would do that so you know we're
really working with the bank so the bank
can provide a loan to that company so
the bank's obligation is to First
liquidate any collateral that's
available
um pursue all the personal guarantors of
the business which are required and then
we would look at what any deficiency
that remains if any at that point after
paying off as much of the loan as they
can from the collateral which typically
covers all of it but if there were a
loss the BFA guarantee would pay a
portion of that remaining loss with the
bank bearing the difference and we would
use our reserves that we set up when we
originally backed the loan
to cover that difference
so do you get some kind of fee from the
tent company that builds up your
reserves yeah that's right um we
actually charge the banks a fee for our
services
um and those fees build up a reserve
um the banks typically charge the
customer that fee it's a service to that
customer it's a service to that bank
they're expected to pay for the usage
and they pay fee and that has
capitalized our reserves for for 30
years and they keep paying the fee every
year the guarantee is in place and so
the minute they don't need it anymore
we get the call to say you know hey we
don't want to keep paying this fee which
we think is great because now the
liability is erased and the market has
done its thing
so so so the worst that could happen
would be there's sort of a major
recession lots of people
are out and and the value of their good
there's collateral is not very good and
therefore the state would have to come
up with whatever this number is is that
right yeah in a in a very
apocalyptic scenario if they all went
out of business at the same time and the
values weren't collateral value wasn't
worth it and the BFA couldn't make up
the difference then the state would be
asked to pay and that's
thankfully never happened we don't
anticipate that ever will
um
you know they do look at the likelihood
of that scenario when they look at our
debt affordability studying our bond
rating is to say is this you know what's
really going to happen here I spoke to
the treasurer on Friday she said she has
no concerns with this increase
you're welcome to confirm that with her
directly of course I have one more
one more okay thank you
so right now you're getting close to
your 115 million total is that right so
so when you're let's say you had
let's say you had 5 million left right
and and three five million projects came
in you would look for whichever one
seemed to be the best
the least risky presumably and fund that
one and say sorry to the other two or
something like that is that right yeah
we would operate on a first come first
serve basis so anyone who was eligible
was the would get the services first as
long as they were deemed to be of you
know low enough risk and a sufficient
public benefit to be eligible period we
don't you know pick it's
if you're eligible you get in line and
we take a look and go from there
oh so you don't sort of think the tent
company is is better than the balloon
company or something else that no uh I
mean I might have opinions on this
balloon company I don't know but
um you know we don't it doesn't it
doesn't work that way I assume yeah
thank you
for other questions from members of the
division
representative McGuire does have an
amendment that he has passed out or you
like to discuss that sure so the very
copy of it sir I I would love a copy
okay oh it's got it it changes the
number so it changes the number from 200
million to 150 million and the the
reason for this change is I looked at
the hit the history of this number is
actually in the law so you don't have to
look too far to see it but it started at
50 million and it went to 80
um in 1993 and then it went to 95 in
1994 and then
um
looks like 21 years later it went to 115
right so for a very long time they
didn't need any extra and then now
they're asking for 200 all right but
it's that's that's a much bigger
increase than it has ever been in the
past right that's that's uh I don't know
what it is
um
close to 100 percent right that's 80 or
something increase right and only eight
years later when the last increase took
21 years to happen so so the 150 million
is
what
um
115 million was in 2015 in today's
dollars so if you apply inflation to 115
million from 2015 you get 150 you
actually get 148 but that's what it is
so it kind of gives them back the same
Authority they had the last time this
was raised that's my my concept would
you like to comment Mr Wallace
sure thank you representative
um we'd be very appreciative of an
increase of 150 million you know a 200
million increase would prevent us from
coming back here again
um you know representative McGuire is
correct inflation gets you right at that
figure we're I think also facing the
fact that we're just busier than we
historically have been
um
you know an increase to 150 million I'd
still be a happy person with a
functioning state agency and uh
you know more is always better for us
but I'll just leave it at that
let's move by representative McGuire's
it's seconded
representative Sweeney
more discussion
uh yes representative evil
um
I guess I in in my experience with the
state treasurer I've found her to be
extremely conservative in her views and
in her estimates as we would want a
Treasurer to be and we haven't confirmed
this with her directly but you said
you've talked to her about the credit
limit and she expressed no concerns
uh yes representative that's that's
correct um I'd also note that the
treasurer is on our board of directors
and is a voting member on every
transaction
um just for the record
representative grassy yeah having having
uh it's not it's not a question but it's
a comment having used this um this you
know their their services in the city of
Rochester to attract businesses there in
both the Sig situation and um and the
saffron situation previously and I was
intimately involved with the saffron
situation you know as Things become more
competitive out there in fact cut group
Cutthroat when it comes to attracting
businesses to a state
the business Finance Authority has been
in a tremendous service to the
communities who have been trying to
attract businesses to the state of New
Hampshire and jobs the state of New
Hampshire
um you know I have no problem with 150
000 I'm sure they would they would love
the 150 million 150 million dollar limit
but the thing is is that are they going
to be back here in four years saying you
know we need it again and is there a
possibility that this could hamstring a
community who has a major corporation
wants to come to New Hampshire
um the
regardless even no matter if they're a
Fortune 500 company or not a lot of
times Banks look at it and say any type
of expansion is risky they're going to
be looking for guarantees and these
these people here help the local
communities get these businesses this is
not impacting the taxpayers one bit this
is only the bond rating and these people
have a tremendous record I would be
opposed to this because I think we need
to give our communities here in the
state of New Hampshire as much as many
tools as we can to compete with other
states because other states are doing
this and a lot more I'll tell you when
we were dealing with saffron I think I
mentioned this we were dealing with
North Carolina and they were it was very
aggressive and it went right down to the
last minute and one of the things that
we got was the business Finance
Authority to come in guaranteeing their
loans and when they did that that closed
the deal for the City of Rochester to
bring a major Aviation company to the
state of New Hampshire
thank you representative McGuire
so let me ask
um do you have a maximum that you will
ever give any one project and and how
much would this extra 35 million how
many years would you project that would
last for you
uh thank you representative there are
maximums in some programs and no
maximums in other programs
so one of our programs actually our most
frequently used program is known as cap
the way cap works is when a bank wants
to make a loan to a small business that
normally wouldn't otherwise be able to
access Credit they can enroll it in cap
the bank pays a fee into an account
the borrower pays a fee into an account
and we put some money into an account
that account grows each time a new cap
deal is enrolled and it's used as a
pooled loan loss reserve for that bank
for that bank's caps customers there's a
loss they can recover from the account
to the Limit that's in the account those
loans are limited to five hundred
thousand dollars right that's been used
by over I think over 5 000 companies now
in the states very active right
um
when we guarantee a line of credit for A
bank's loan to a company that has a
limit of two million dollars per
transaction
term loans for real estate and Equipment
have no statutory limit so it's a little
difficult to predict
um but I'll give you an example so the
six hour transaction the BFA approved
just a few weeks ago to really expand
that company they have a very new
exciting situation it's going to employ
a ton of people is a 33 million dollar
transaction right so if it's a line of
credit I would say this might last us
quite a while you know it could be a few
years before we're back if another big
opportunity comes it could use this
entire increase in one Transit and one
foul swoop and we'd be back here
you know as soon as I could convince
someone to schedule me and so
so it's a little hard to guess if you
had to pin me down representative I'd
say
um
12 months to 24 months
representative
thank you Mr chair just two comments um
I believe that it's more than reasonable
to go to the 200 million because if you
look at it it's it's 2.5 x what it was
in 1993 and things have gone way up more
than 2.5 x since then and the other
thing I would say is I believe that this
is an important uh function that keeps
the New Hampshire advantage in getting
businesses here uh so I I personally
would would grant them the 200 million
thank you representative
from one Vernon
also uh more or less just a comment
I feel uh
I feel pretty good about leaving it at
the 200 particularly as the say
treasurers we all know was very
conservative
system aboard
and will have a voice in overlooking
things so I too am I I don't really see
the need to lower lower the limit
thanks representative griffiniti any
other comments
see
ing none are I'll I'll just comment I
did ask a question but I agree with um
representative cambrells and and Griffin
and uh grassy that they seem extremely
solid they seem extremely well managed
they seem conservative and I think that
our state is in competition with our
area States and that this would really
continue to bolster our competitive
advantages in the state which we're very
interested in bolstering so I'll be
voting um
respectfully against the motion and
would support leaving the cap as it is
in hb2
seeing no further questions with the
clerk please call the roll
um
I don't know do we have an amendment
number
Mr Hoffman we requested this from OLS at
5 30 this morning
I just want you not ready yet yeah no
number yet two
hang on guys it's gonna be a long day
I want to get sure to make sure my
papers are in order okay uh
representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin
no
representative Sweeney no
Representative cambrells no
representative uh grassy
no
representative Hewitt no the clerk votes
no representative leishman yes
okay all right uh the vote is
six to two against the um Amendment so
the motion fails and so we just leave it
as it is right that's correct
uh thank you Mr Wallace nice to see you
yes thank you and thank you everybody
sincerely thank you
we have another item that we
move to the top of the pile this morning
and commissioner Stewart is here to
speak to an amendment that was offered
on Friday afternoon concerning the New
Hampshire public television request of
five hundred thousand dollars a year
right
or if you could please state your name
for the record and this is on the
McGuire amendment that was handed out on
Friday
good morning Sarah Stewart commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources
does everybody have a copy of the
amendment
I believe
yes that's correct yeah
all right representative McGuire would
like to speak to his
Amendment
so um
this is something that used to be in the
budget until 12 years ago representative
Allen Court
um
uh talked us into getting rid of it I
guess it didn't take any talking into in
my mind but
um so it hasn't been in the budget for
for 12 years
um
and in my mind this is inappropriate use
of public funds
um
the way we get money from taxpayers is
by force we we take a certain amount of
money
and in a lot of ways we you know we use
it for very legitimate purposes in many
ways right courts prisons Etc we also
use it for uh effectively charitable
things elderly disabled education and so
on
but here we're using it for creation of
of television
something that the the public is
perfectly capable of funding on their
own uh they don't they don't need our
help
um the the amount of video and
television and programming and so on has
exploded and I think that other areas of
the budget are much more deserving than
this one we've been talking this morning
to division three and they're struggling
with rates for Medicaid and so on right
so
um so I just don't think this
expenditure is Justified it's as simple
as that
commissioner Stewart
thank you
um so I am here today representing my
agency and this is funding that would go
into the
um Council on the Arts account and then
the council on the Arts would pass the
funding over to public television so I
just want to make sure that that that's
clear to everybody
um a couple of points that I'd like to
make number one is historically the New
Hampshire State Council on the Arts has
to
um be very creative in finding a match
for their federal funds and I think we
discussed this a little bit the last not
last time at the time before that I was
here
um because the um the the national Arts
organization issues an amount of money
for each state and each state then has
to come up with a dollar for dollar
match for that fund and that often has
been a struggle for for the Arts to do
so they count they count my time towards
that and some other
um increment moose plate dollars for
example because they process a lot of
moose plate dollars to make the to make
the match work so just for a dollar for
dollar
exercise having some flexibility with
finding a match for the federal
allocation would be very nice for the
Arts to have
um we won't know what our budget is
until the end of this budget season for
the Arts so we don't know what we'll
need to come up with the match it's the
governor was very generous I think to
the Arts budget in his version of the
budget but as you know we won't know
until hopefully June uh what the what
the budget will be and then we'll have
to figure out how to match that for to
to achieve our federal allocation so
that's one piece of it
um the other piece I would say is that
uh the programming that is um
plant in in talks with public television
it was very important for me to
understand that there could be some uh
Synergy between the work that the
Council on the Arts is doing and the
programming that they could enhance with
this money and our Council on the Arts
is a staff of about seven people to
magnify some of the work that they do to
support the Arts throughout the state
um you know we see a direct benefit to
Showcase uh the the creative economy
here in New Hampshire that is booming
and everywhere in every region of the
state so there is a strategic Alliance
if you look at it that way with the
programming at New Hampshire public
television I do not work for New
Hampshire public television Peter Fred
who's the head of the New Hampshire
public television is here if there are
specific programming questions that I
would defer to him
um but uh I I'm here to answer any other
questions
questions of the commissioner
representative Griffin
I I think uh this amendment
representative Maguire's Amendment came
up
while we were discussing the State
Library
and in my mind
the billion dollars is better spent
from a State library and rescuing the
the uh the things that we have over
there before there before it's too late
to rescue them
so in my mind this is a
it's really a trade-off
between
public television which I think is
pretty well funded by the federal
government to begin with
and protecting our own
local resources held in by a State
Library
would you like to comment on that or uh
I believe the um the final
amount that was voted on for the State
library was 750 000 that's correct
um which was slightly less than the 1
million so maybe we have some
flexibility with this allocation to make
up the difference
representative grassy
uh do you have any how much I mean are
we missing out on federal funds because
we're not being able to provide the
match
and what is that number if you know have
fanned okay so we have we have not in re
since I've been here so I can only speak
to recent history we have not missed out
on federal funds we have had but we've
had to
um
uh stress over it
um and and kind of
you know have a very uh cumbersome
spreadsheet to to prove to the Feds that
we are matching it with
um you know the hours that the staff
spends and other uh funding so no to be
honest we have not we have not had to
turn away Federal funding but it's
always a fear
thank you
it's an honor
representative Kimbrell's no
oh okay
are there any further questions on the
McGuire Amendment
representable
having made the motion to put 750
000 plus a tour into HB 2 for purposes
of the library
um and following up on representative
Griffin's comment
would there be any interest or could I
persuade the division to maybe give if
this is if if if the public TV funding
is not going to be supported could we
put some more money into the library
effort
representative Griffin
I certainly would be supportive to put
the library amount back to a million
dollars if if this passes
would you want to add more than that
[Laughter]
we'll have two tours yeah whatever I'm
trying to help
representative McGuire are you willing
to modify your Amendment
to add 250 total for the biennium back
to the library yeah all right sure
and that would be with the
reviso that this is supported well you
can add it to the segment right
all right is there a second to that
representative Griffin
seeing no further questions if the
cleric would like to call the role
okay I want to get this straight motion
to add
250k back to the library
I think it's fun well this is uh this
would be one
moving the five hundred thousand dollars
that's it
it's a million overall but 500 000 per
year so a million
in hb1 I believe this is a budget line
is that right Melissa
I thought they were both HP one
um no the library was hb2 yeah
guys no that's not a problem so when the
cleric is ready if she'll please call
the roll we all clearance to support the
McGuire initial request to removing one
million dollars from New Hampshire
public television and restoring 250
000 to the library bringing that amount
to one million dollars
all right
all right representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrose yes
representative grassy
feel the same okay representative Hewitt
yes
uh yes the clerk votes yes
representation yes chair I mean
represent Peter is fine
who should I coordinate the tour with
representative Ebel after we get done
with the budget you got it
yeah thanks commissioner
can't uh move on to two items that have
been hanging back here for a while we
have uh House Bill 436 relative to group
two retirement under transition
Provisions uh representative Maguire is
prepared an amendment maybe you will
speak to I'm wondering if we should take
them in the other order since
maybe we should save some money before
we spend it or
what do you think well it's up to you
you're offering to a different Amendment
so if you'd like to take up 571 you're
welcome to do that yeah I think of that
would make more sense all right
this is 4 37.
Melissa handout 571
we actually don't have that Amendment
back problem oh well yeah okay there's
still one and I'll just talk
um yeah sure yeah okay so if as you
recall House Bill 571 was a cola
and it added to group two
um retirement so it was for those who
are retired at least 10 years already so
um and and it was a five percent Cola
for those retired 10 through 19 years
and then a 10 Cola for those retired 20
plus years right and it was a permanent
Cola so that that would be added to
ongoing
um their ongoing retirement so
um I'm proposing I actually have two
versions of an amendment for you
um both of them are one-time payments
they're not ongoing permanent payments
um and they're both for the same group
of people
um so the the overall cost is we asked
them what's the cost of one year's worth
of this bill of House Bill 571 the
answer was 8.8 million so it's it's
roughly in that picture in that ballpark
um and what what it what the two
amendments are slightly different in the
sense that
um one amendment is uh two thousand
dollars I think this is right two
thousand dollars for the first group The
the 10 to 19 year group three thousand
dollars for the 20 plus group right
um and the other amendment is a ramp so
it starts it's a ramp that starts at one
thousand dollars for those retired ten
years it's like twelve hundred dollars
for those 11 years fourteen hundred
dollars for those
Etc up to the three thousand dollars and
then it's the three thousand dollars for
those that are 20 plus years if you see
what I mean so there's there's no step
there's no big step in the in the Second
Amendment but
um
yeah and and the other thing we add that
we added to it is
um an overall cap of a hundred thousand
dollars so if it's someone is already
has a has a pension of a hundred
thousand dollars or more they would not
be getting these this one-time payment
could I just clarify it so we only have
one of the Amendments at this point I
mean I have I have zero eight nine
oh that's 436 okay so we don't know
sorry so we don't have
571. we don't we sent that to them
Saturday at six o'clock at night ish and
they informed me this morning they were
still working on it
yeah okay so it may be a little
premature yeah all right too far into
this okay unfortunately we don't have it
we hope that we would have it
all right all right well let's switch
gears then then
thank you for doing it yeah all right so
um
but the concept is that right now on our
on our total our grand total
um House Bill 571 is 84 million this
would make it more like 10 you know
eight nine or ten something like that so
so that helps us balance the budget
significantly all right house bill 436.
so
um this was a bill very strongly passed
the house and it you know this is a
truly bipartisan bill in the sense that
a majority of both the Democrats and the
majority of the Republicans voted for
this right obviously stronger on one
side than the other but but it was but
it you know it wasn't bipartisan in the
sense that you know it got all of this
and two of these or something like that
it it was a real bipartisan you know I
think that's the way the word should be
defined but anyways
um
but it's very expensive this is a very
expensive bill and we got this analysis
from the um
from from the retirement system
that says so so the way the bill is
planned to spend is 25 million in in 10
years each each year for 10 years so
starting in fiscal year 25 so the second
year of the biennium
and
um it has some other changes that add
um
so so it's a little bit confusing but it
it adds uh this one point if you see the
paper here one essentially 1.7 percent
to the employer rates for police and
fire but the 25 million over time is
like
22.7 million too much right so it it
lowers the unfunded liability by 22.7
million but it does raise employer rates
by one point something
um
per year
um so I've
um I'm proposing that we amend it that
we add it to house bill 2. but we amend
it
slightly to make it a little bit less
expensive and that's by doing three
things so one of them was the amendment
we we agreed to last week right if you
remember the original Bill had a the
original bill has a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollar cap on
um the pensions for this group and it
and it had an accelerator for that cap
so so it would go up by one and a
quarter percent per year so we we took
off that change so so it's just flat
it's a flat cap
okay
um
yeah so that's that's in section five of
the bill
um so we kept that
actually I thought that was five they
changed it so it's now
three is four I guess
yeah oh okay so it's that's in section
three of this bill
of this amendment the other thing that I
did was remove sections two and three of
the original bill so sections two and
three had to do with
what is
compensation all right so
um
back in 2011
um compensation for this this group of
people was the average of the top three
years of of uh pay and it was changed to
the top five years and it also included
um special special duty pay things like
um if a police officer does uh
it helps out with a like a like an arena
event or something and gets extra pay I
think that was used to be counted and
it's no longer as counted so
um so
by removing sections two and three we
keep the modern definition of what pay
is for this group
which is what it is now in law and we do
not revert it to the definition that was
existing in 2011. okay
but this bill does keep the the main
expensive part of the part of the of the
cost which is
that in 2011 this group
um the way their pension was calculated
was average final average compensation
times number of years of service times
two and a half percent
and what it was changed in 2011 so that
for some of this group it was now 2.4
percent and for some it was 2.3 percent
and some was 2.2 percent and so on
and so this Bill gets rid of that it
puts all these people back at two and a
half percent but does it over time in a
way that encourages them to stay working
for another couple years beyond their
normal uh retirement
okay so
um it's phased in over time
and
um so all that's that part is is
unchanged from the original bill in this
amendment
so
hopefully that's clear so so again
compared to the original Bill we kept
the definition of of
earned income
all right and we kept the cap changes
that we did last week but otherwise this
is the original Bill okay
Mr Carlin would you like to
I probably don't want to come forward to
uh thank you Mr chair for the record uh
Marty Carlin from the New Hampshire
retirement system who just saw this
amendment a minute ago oh okay it was
so you really haven't had a chance to
really go through it obviously no no
um I just off the top of my head the
changes to the definition of variable
compensation and the inclusion of unused
sick and vacation time are a significant
change to the bill and would uh lower
the cost significantly but again I
actually would have to tell us exactly
how much
you know that that's that's a major
change in of a original bill
um the 125 uh raising the cab from 125
to 120 and not having that escalator in
it that was an amendment brought forth
at the committee accepted last week and
we provided the information LBA which
you have received over the weekend about
the cost decrease for that this would
reduce the cost of the bill by an
indeterminate amount at this point
um you know there's others who may want
to speak about the policy implications
but I you know that's really not our
place to
get into that
questions for Mr Carlin
well seeing none I guess you get off the
book a little bit easier today I'll be
around is it possible that you could get
us an analysis of the
we're supposed to have everything done
as you know by tomorrow
no so
yes representative Griffin
it's not necessary necessarily a comment
I mean a question
but
I think
looking at this it's progress
but I think the reason we originally
retain the bill
they think we did
uh was it still needs a lot of work
it's it's a lot of money
and
and I don't think we're gonna save it in
a day
and if we do we're probably going to
make Samaras
in the process of doing it well that's
just my comment
for other comments or questions
representative Sweeney I I agree that
the bill is a lot of money as originally
proposed but as representative McGuire
said it was a bill that bipartisan
support for the policy changes when it
first came to the house as we craft the
budget looking to build a budget that we
can
pass
um
we should be mindful of the costs and
make sure that we're at least putting
away the money if we have to keep
working on the policy we keep working on
the policy but making sure we have a
home to fund it when we can get to a
conclusion again I don't know if we can
do that by tomorrow's deadline of
getting the our section of the budget
out of this division but we should be
mindful of this this large moving piece
and making sure that we find a home for
it
um whatever we can however we can do
that we we need to do that
thanks representative Sweeney uh
representative McGuire you have anything
else to add or
well I maybe I should say the motivation
for taking out sections two and three
so sections two and three are what we
would call we used to call spiking right
so the idea is that because pensions are
based on the the highest three earning
years of compensation or well now five
but at the time three
um
what employees were able to do and you
know what it's not there there's any
blame involved I mean it's just it is
what it is is by working lots of
overtime or extra Duty or whatever in
their final few years they were able to
make a much higher pension than they
would have had otherwise
and the problem is the money to pay for
those higher pensions wasn't being saved
over their working career right the
money being saved over their working
career to pay for pensions is based on
their current salaries and then the
amount of overtime they work and all
that other stuff but but to have a
mechanism that allows employees to to
sort of artificially boost their final
pay
is problematic for the retirement system
because
there's no money in it to cover those
things right so that was the reason that
those changes were made and they were
made not just for group two but for all
the groups right for the entire system
so the entire system uses a fairly
consistent
um since 2011 definition of final pay of
average final compensation so so that's
why I think it's it you know asking to
change that particular part is not
really reasonable in my in my opinion
but the other parts are more reasonable
thank you
so the division we want to look at this
for another couple of hours another day
I see nodding heads
you know we only have a day we have to
have everything done as you know
tomorrow representative evil
well I would just say in the meantime
we'd also get the 571 and then
discussions and um I think all of that
would filter into our brains when we
make a final decision
all right I think we should also look at
the the tax related
oh the uh communication communication
delete interest and yeah okay interest
in dividends that's kind of connected
too
all right so hopefully we'll have some
information uh the language for both of
these amendments uh maybe by this
afternoon Melissa can we kind of I know
it's hard to push them across the street
but I will reach out to them again and
hopefully be able to get you something
by this afternoon because representative
McGuire and I spoke of some significant
changes over the weekend uh that I think
the division needs to hear about too and
at the same time we have those
amendments do you have the tax related
changes yeah oh you do have those okay
yeah so why don't we pass those out the
cfp and IND yeah yeah
laughs
this is easier I guess okay
so for the folks that came to hear the
discussion on these two retirement bills
it doesn't look like we'll be hearing
anything directly as far as until we get
the Amendments from OLS the other one is
house bill 250.
we should probably talk about that yeah
we'll do these first okay
because we're going to be conducting
that today so right I'm hoping we can
like at 11 o'clock get to the other
issues
this way
thanks
okay all right representative
so thank you Mr chairman so
if we pass House Bill 436 whether the
way I said in this amendment or some
other way
it means we're going to need a revenue
source
to pay for it over a long period of time
right because it spends money for 10
years
and so the obvious place to look there
is the communication Services tax right
communication Services tax in the budget
goes away
um this this biennium and it's 58
million dollars a year
House Bill 430
I'm sorry a year 58 million 56 million
the biennium right right all right sorry
you're right 28 million a year 29.
House Bill 436 25 a year right rough up
rough balance there and so and it's an
ongoing a possible ongoing source of
Revenue so
um so what this bill does
is restore the communication Services
tax that's line one
but as a kind of compensation
for the part of the committee myself
included who like tax cuts
it
sunsets the interest in dividends tax
two years earlier than it otherwise
would in current law so in current law
the interest in dividends tax is being
said and set on January 1st 2027 this
would make it January 1st 2025.
all right now these two changes together
um the way it's written in this
amendment is actually a net plus for
this particular budget so for this
particular biennium it's roughly I think
we've decided a 24 million dollar
plus it will be a negative to the next
biennium
by I estimate roughly 40 million dollars
but ongoing for future bienniums it's a
net plus of of uh 50 something billion
for the bienniums right so so enough to
cover effectively enough to cover the
house bill 436 costs
and so
um and I think that you know that should
appeal to those who want House Bill 436
and it should appeal to those who would
like to see the interest in dividends
tax sunset
so I think this is a good compromise
comments representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um I support moving up the phase out of
interest and dividends
um I like the idea that we're
restoring the communications tax to find
the home for 436 and sort of
incorporating it there with based on my
my brain
um the uh I mean I haven't yeah so the
the revenue from the Communication
Service acts would fund would bring in
more than the cost of 436 as we amended
it on Friday correct
so that would even out there a little
bit and then it's the the 436 is the
10-year increase so can we
would we also be able to based on the
testimony that we heard from uh the tax
office the service tax continues to go
down
so maybe even in in this bill in this
budget include that in 10 years once 436
is funded the Communication Service tax
is abolished is the returns for that 10
years from now when we're 90 using data
for phone calls anyways is going to be
minimal so that's just my but I think we
can find through this find the home for
436 as we mentioned on Friday
and and move forward with with a tax cut
that a portion of the house uh would
like to say represent McGuire thank you
yeah I guess I'm willing to let
whoever's sitting in this chair it will
not be me
in 10 years time
um make that kind of decision so
representative camber house thank you
thank you Mr chair I I also like this
plan because I I want to do what's right
with 436 but we have to we must fund it
and I think that the communications tax
is a great way to go about it as long as
we can you know appease Everyone by also
pulling in the dividend and interest tax
um my question would be to
representative McGuire
um your other Amendment so we know that
the initial bill is 25 million dollars a
year what would the your other Amendment
do to that 25 is it bring it down a
little because that's what I like to
know
the I think
um I don't know specific yes it makes it
less
the amount less is is unknown presumably
um it won't be known by the when the
house it won't necessarily be known when
the house has to act on on the budget
but at the end of the day I mean when it
gets to the Senate and and when we get
to the committee of conference then we
will have a much clearer picture but it
is less yeah okay Paul so my opinion on
that then is that everybody has to give
a little here and I believe that they
they're not going to get the whole ball
of wax but they're going to get most of
it and I do believe everyone has to give
into this in order to kind of make
everybody happy and so I like your plan
and I think also what you did was fair
because like you said when you talked
about the spiking that is a known issue
and uh and and I think it's it's right
for everyone to give into this for the
to fix the situation once and for all so
further comments representable
so I'm looking at the HR 17 from house
ways and means that they presented and
we tabled and what it says for the
interests and dividends and tax for 2024
is
112.8 million and for 2025 it's 89.4
and the CST
is 28
0.9 and 28.9 so there's a radical
difference between the two numbers
so I know I mean we don't have like the
the analysis yes we do actually you do
so I don't know if you have it to hand
out but we did get a kind of breakdown
from dra year by year of what the
interest in dividends tax collects
sure I don't have it I don't have it to
hand out at this moment this moment can
get ready it is based it's based on the
um they're 22 collections so it wasn't
updated with the HR 17 yet
so I can explain so
under this proposal
only the last six months of the interest
and dividends tax from this biennium the
current biennium will go away so we
would have the hundred and whatever the
the first years fiscal year 24's value
unchanged fiscal year 25's value
would go down but
it's
not by half of that value so that that
value is 89 million right but it would
go down by roughly a third of that value
because
it's the the interest in dividends tax
is charged on that on a calendar year
basis so so this the six months you're
missing
it's the rate is already programmed to
go down if you see what I mean like it's
three percent the first six months and
and two percent the second six months of
fiscal year
25 okay so so it isn't very much this is
the point okay thank you um
so
speaking for myself I would be in favor
of restoring the CST but I really don't
see why there has to be a trade-off here
I don't know why we can't just restore
the CST to help fund
hb436 and leave everything the way it is
I mean like all of you I sat through the
hearing last week I listened to the
unbelievable needs of folks that have
developed mentally disabled children
that have disabled children there's
nursing home issues there's so many many
things and while I support doing the
right thing on 4 36 I couldn't support
trading off IND for CST I would rather
just not repeal CST at all
it would appear that we're heading for
an impasse which I hope we can avoid
representative grassy
first of all I'd just like to make one
comment is having served on the
Rochester city council for many years
the spiking Clause is something that
spiking issue is certainly something
that I 100 support you on because I
think it's something that needs to be
needs to be addressed and it was
something that we all anguished over
every year when we saw our payments come
through but
um I think that as far and I support it
it's great to see that you've you know
decide that you know we need to keep the
communications tax because we and and to
fund this this you know the particular
things that we have to do in the
retirement system and that's that's good
but I think that you know representative
evil did mention that after the public
hearing that we had the other day and
some of the reimbursement rates that are
far inadequate that we have for services
that are out there right now to make a
judgment on this now uh for the interest
in dividends tax
um would would not be a responsible
thing to do at the end
when we can see what we have funded and
what we are unable to fund or what we
decide not to fund then that may be a
better time to look at it because if the
budget comes out and we have more money
than we need
then
that's fine
but if we don't have more money we need
and we see that there are important
things that the citizens of our state
need
then you know we may want to look at
this as a way to fund some of those
programs that we unfortunately because
of a cut like this we may be maybe
having to cut
and I would instead of having to cut
particularly like reimbursement rates
which should be higher and other
programs I mean we don't we still don't
know what the other divisions are
bringing in uh and until we do I think
we uh it would be responsible to to take
this action
representable hi I just had I just had
one other comment I actually went back
and I looked at the live stream uh on
ways and means when they were assessing
uh bills that related to the CST repeal
that they looked at bills that were
accelerating the phase out of IND there
was discussion at that point about
concerns about revenue and they felt
that none of those decisions should be
made at this time and they retained all
the bills and
I would argue that we're interposing the
Judgment of ways and means who are the
experts on this
um for our own in making a decision like
this and again they actually did retain
a bill on the basis of concern about
revenues that would be repeal the CST I
think at some point we thought maybe
they were leaving the decision to us and
maybe they kind of were but that is not
what was stated on during the retain
hearing
Melissa and Mr Hoffman would you reach
out to commissioner stepp and get
something fairly quickly from her as far
as accelerating the repeal
and with the impact it would have
because we we have a lot of numbers in
the air and as far as ways and means we
accepted their recommendations but we
have to as we all know make a decision
and wouldn't be nice to have the
Commissioners weigh in on that
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman speaking to
seek consensus and compromise which can
doesn't have to be a bad word if we are
smart about it there's a coalition of
the of the Full House and within this
Division and within our overall
committee that wants to see
that that likes the idea of getting rid
of the Communication Service tax there's
a coalition along very similar lines
that would like to speed up the phase
out of interest and dividends that we
started in the last budget and and make
that work so that it phases out sooner
and there's a coalition it's pretty
broad that wants 436 and likes the
amendment from Friday that we discussed
and had we don't have the analysis fully
yet of the amendment that was brought
forward today in my head it does seem
clear that we can trade
the Communication Service tax repeal
that was proposed in the governor's
budget speed up the interest in
dividends tax cut and phase out to give
those that want to reduce taxes
something to cheer on in this budget and
incorporate and settle for the 436 as
amended on Friday
and and that should be something that
the numbers in my head seem to work and
that could be something that this
division can get behind unanimously sell
it to the full finance and and let's
just do a Voice vote for the budget and
three that last part was a joke that was
a joke yeah but I I think with all these
elements all these all the balls were
juggling in the air right now we can
catch them all and we can make it work
where everybody's not getting everything
they want but we're all getting
something that we can go home and be
proud of and we can talk to our groups
and our people that we're here to
represent and say hey I went in fighting
for this we got this and that's still a
good thing that we can say we accomplish
for the people of New Hampshire
obviously there's going to be other
parts of the budget where we're going to
fight tooth and nail on I think in our
division with these being kind of the
the home stretch for where our budget's
going to end up we can
436 from Friday
restore the Communication Service tax
and the idea that it will fund 436 from
Friday for the next 10 years and speed
up the interest in dividends tax for a
minimal budget impact this budget in
order to just show people that we all
gave up a little but we're all in the
end getting pretty substantially a lot
so that's my two cents that's my way of
thinking before seeing fiscal notes on
on any various thing I think that's
where we can come together as a division
and then hopefully as a finance
committee on those areas so that's what
I would advocate for and be supportive
of in this uh final stretch
well said representative Sweeney
representative McGuire and I met with Mr
Kane this morning and some other folks
from the different divisions and our
division is in very good shape right now
we actually could based on some of the
decisions we make today
pass some money over to uh division
three for Home Care bring that
percentage up from 3.1 to maybe more is
another way of bringing people to the
table
um and this division has worked very
well you'll find representative grassy
being new but we've worked very well in
reaching many good compromises I think
and to get a budget through we need to
compromise we cannot go to the house
floor without a budget that is passed
because we've been there before I think
representative Griffin and maybe McGuire
and I and representative evil have
witnessed what happens when a budget
goes down the house is no position with
the Senate so we need to get somewhere
in representative cambrell's yes thank
you Mr chair again representative
Sweeney said it all I think it was
perfect and I I think that
um it's incumbent upon us to be one of
those divisions that sends
recommendations with you know good solid
numbers behind them because this this is
that critical and uh and I think that
this compromise that we've discussed
it's a win-win for everyone I mean
everybody maybe doesn't get 100 but
everybody gets 90 95 percent out of this
um so I think it's a great compromise
package when you look at it as a whole
thank you did you get any indication
Melissa or Mike when we might get any
response from OLS as far as the
additional amendments the language
um for the 571 I just got an email
saying they were just about done with
the First Amendment and they're working
on the Second Amendment and they'll hope
to have it back to me today
all right and able to send an email to
commissioner Steph's office or I sent
her an email while we were sitting here
asking for that perfect practical impact
of the IND repeal using HR 17 data all
right representative McGuire no
representation oh I'm sorry
representative Griffin
yeah as far as this latest Amendment
uh
I think it's my problem all along with
has been that we were encumbering
future legislators
and I don't think we should do
and I think this amendment
by
salvaging the communications tax to pay
for it
what we doing 436
and as a trade-off speed up the
interests and dividends thing it seems
to me like it's a workable solution
nobody gets everything they want but
um we don't encumber a future a future
legislator
legislature and uh
from my viewpoint that's very important
I think a lot of the problems that we're
dealing with
come from the past and I think we have
to be careful not to leave
problems for the future
thank you so representative evil
appreciate
far and I too want a bipartisan solution
the only thing that I'd say is that one
of the reasons that the governor gave
for getting rid of the CST is that he
thought it was a decreasing Revenue
source so even though we can argue that
this will pay for um
436 going forward there is not
necessarily a guarantee of that
um because again it was already a
declining
resource so and as far as you know
trying to
uh satisfy some folks on the on having a
tax cut in this budget I would say that
the IND is already being phased out on a
schedule that is a tax cut and I'm not
sure that we need to
accelerate it even more to to have
another tax cut so that would be I I
think for my caucus it would be very
difficult to make this agreement
representative McGuire
yeah so
let me talk about why the interest and
dividends tax is
um problem is important
um
so in my mind
this tax is is economically the most
destructive one we have
um
in general in order in order to improve
the economy
the we need to have savings savings is
how savings is what makes tomorrow
better than today
right and and in general in economic
terms that's happiness right if you're
cons if tomorrow is better than today
um you you feel good right you things
are better so things are improving
improving over time
but in economic terms in order to make
tomorrow better than today you can't
consume everything you create today you
have to save
and the interest in dividends tax is a
direct tax on savings
right so it's something we actually want
to encourage not discourage when you tax
something you get less of it and we do
that explicitly in many ways right we
tax cigarettes we tax liquor we tax
things with that we deliberately want to
discourage
um the communication tax is a
consumption type tax it's a it's a it's
it discourages a little bit
talking on the phone all right but it
doesn't have broader Economic
Consequences in the way that the
interest in dividends tax does because
the interest and dividends tax is a tax
on Capital formation and its attacks on
savings and savings is what makes the
economy get better over time so it's
important to to Really Sunset it and and
this amendment is saying to both sides
let's take the bird in the hand
for the two in the bush right so that
that's what this is about
thank you
sorry represent grassy if I could just
ask a question representative McGuire
how much savings do you have to have in
the bank before you have to start paying
the interest in dividends tax because if
I'm not mistaken there is an exemption
that you only stop paying after a
certain amount I mean how much money
would you have to have in the bank
before you stop paying that tax
if you're asking about the details yeah
it does have a I think it's
twenty four hundred dollars if you're
you're asking about
of there's a minimum right so you have
to have it's it's charging you five
percent of your interest and dividends
once it's over I think it's 2400 it's
different for a couple and for a single
that kind of thing yeah but I don't know
the details what's the and by the way
that you would have to have in the bank
is what I'm interested in
oh
well that just depends on how you invest
right so
um
yeah I mean it depends on what kind of
stocks you have what kind of portfolio
and it basically affects the retirees
who the uh one of their biggest sources
of income in retirement is their
dividends and their interests on their
Investments so
we're moving a little off topic
we need to uh get back to uh where we
were a little earlier once we get the
information from the commissioner and
the draft amendments which we're waiting
on will get back into this deeper but I
appreciate everybody's comments uh
as you all know we have a number of
bills most the bills being exact this
afternoon are ours except one and at
some point probably at 11 30 I want to
just go over everything so everybody
knows where they are and what they have
to speak to if they have forgotten uh
Janet's working on that sheet as soon as
she has that we'll have that in front of
us but
maybe if we could move to um
areas that we have to button up and
that's the uh additional requests there
are a number we have a sheet given to us
on Friday
and as you recall we acted on the
department of administrative services
and addressed three out of six items
but as you'll see below that sheet if
you have it in front of you that's dated
there are a number of items that uh it
says sheet here okay
so moving if anyone doesn't have it
um
Mr Hoffman's got a brand new sheet for
us with the updates
yeah that would be perfect that would be
perfect save everyone from trying to dig
and find the old one
so the new one will show the changes
we've already done so it makes it a
little easier to follow we didn't do
many last week but it gives you a better
idea where we stand
thanks yes
foreign
so you see there's a significant amount
of pending Decisions by departments
yeah it adds up when you start telling
people that give us your want was uh
so agriculture marketing and food see
additional position is there are there
any thoughts those are other funds
members any thoughts
uh representative McGuire is giving me a
muffled yes
I think it's a muffled no no
they should have yeah I don't remember
them making a strong case
all right did they make a strong case
for this I don't really remember I don't
recall to be honest did you just
um
aren't we recommending passage of a bill
to help with their I.T we did do that
yeah we did do that
so that's a no is everybody okay with
that but if I may I I wasn't here for
the presentation it was before me but uh
the thing is having worked with the soil
conservation services in the past as a
town planner I found that they were very
very uh supportive I don't know what
this position does uh but the thing is
is that towns and municipalities uh when
there's construction going on in their
communities or plans being presented
these people have been tremendously
helpful to us and I don't know what
again I don't know what this position is
but if it's one that services and
provides technical support to the
communities
um I would think it would be of
tremendous value with the development
that's going on and conservation
situations Mr Hoffman any recollection
uh I know they've already got folks
embedded doing this this is an
additional yes this was a request in the
um
to the governor's budget phase to be
generally funded position but when the
commissioner came into division one
he said that they would be able to fund
it from this fund so it wouldn't be
General it's other funds yeah
you're going to change your yeah if it's
other funds it's not right yeah all
right uh then we're okay with that
moving down to board of texts and land
Appeals
it's a small amount of money it's a
case management database 19
000. yeah I mean I totally support this
yeah they seem kind of struggling so
it's a yes yes
it is kind of double County
in my uh you're smiling so I know you
want to explain how it is done two
different funds yeah
it's one amount of money that is counted
twice the way they budget the transfers
so
in the office of information
technology they have an expense but the
source of the money for that expense is
a transfer from the other department
at the end of house bill one there's a
netting out of that so you can see the
the gross minus the interagency
transfers to give you a net number
so you're right it's coming from General
but then it will show up on doit as
other but it's really General funds but
they show it as others coming from the
agency but it's it's rather confusing
how it's done but so we're okay with
Board of tax and land appeals yes
okay we have uh the request from the
Small Business Development Center for
additional funding
again I'm a kind of a loss anybody
recall it was a hundred and ten thousand
Representatives I I remember it I think
they had uh 390
000 and when we talked about it during
the hearing and um uh commissioner
Caswell was definitely supportive of the
increase we had a fairly convincing
document letter that outlined for us why
the increase was worthwhile they really
helped support small businesses and I
was uh quite struck by uh maybe you guys
got the email this week I think it went
to all legislators from the SBA and
their small business of the year was
from Mont Vernon and they quoted them
with in very glowing terms about how
great this fund is
um I mean if people didn't want to go
the full 110 maybe we could at least get
get them up to 450 from 390 I think
anything would be helpful to them
further
thoughts representative McGuire yeah I'm
looking at the grand total and Page four
11 million dollars yeah so I'm worried
we don't have this kind of money so well
the more we spend in general we'll find
soon
the less we have for other things
yeah
yeah so so I to me this would be a low
priority I don't know
I don't mind just putting it on hold and
then we'll just wander our way through
the rest of these okay thank you
well I'm just like so the big hunk here
is the case management system I don't I
don't remember very well the discussion
on that
I do recall they made quite a pitch for
Bots well they kind of need
I'm tired
again this is
these are all things that were presented
to the governor
and he did not include in his budget
and so unless unless in their
presentation before us
they made a very strong case
uh
I would think we'd go along with the
executive department
and not from these
wild Advocate obviously has its hands
full so you know
this is really hard because none of us
remember what's ahead of us here to make
judgments along the way so I mean this
is another one there are some of these
numbers are so small maybe we could help
them out after we look at what the the
other things are we could just come back
to it I mean I'd argue the same thing
from the Human Rights Commission I mean
they made they really sounded like they
were stressed to the max
um
I don't know what
could
we have to be cautious
not much we hold here because again I
know well I'm just looking the D.O.T
stuff is a lot of just text well the
doit stuff is off mostly all other I
believe and it's just a double
accounting to put it easy yes
representative yes Mr chair I would be
inclined to maybe give them the obvious
little things that they would need like
additional training and then State and
out of state travel and kill the rest
so they get the basic stuff that they
need the those three things are obvious
and then again I don't recall the case
management system you know being some
I don't know I listen pretty attentively
to all the presentations and I don't
really recall a great case for that
being made so and the LBA has ranked
he's based on what they suggest you'll
see the Bold numbers that was there I
believe ranking
yeah actually we took where the agencies
gave us rankings we used their
priorities yeah
so kill one five through seven and keep
two three and four would be my
recommendation
okay
it's a two three and four is that
correct representative cameras that's
correct
can't have it it's a big number
representative Sweeney thank you I just
want clarify so PR representative is
press relations public relations or
something or training and training
there's not like another acronym in the
child advocate
dichotomy then Melissa PR it's a public
relations public relations
all right it would appear that we're
pretty close to two three and four
Mike and Melissa add those three items
please
Human Rights Commission
again that was another we heard they
were struggling as far as um
their workload and behind and I think
they also told us as they closed cases
and somebody can correct me if I'm wrong
that they get some federal matching
money is that correct Melissa or Mike am
I remembering that correctly
yeah
they do receive some federal
participation
depending on the type of case they're
working on I guess some of those cases
are available to be covered by federal
funds and others are not
all right thoughts from
the division
this is representative cameras well yeah
my recollection was that they weren't
very good with the math and they were
showing that they were closing more
cases every year and yet the caseload
they were getting new cases but they
were closing more cases and they were
getting new and yet their total raw
caseload just stayed steady so they
didn't make a great presentation my
opinion in terms of knowing their
numbers and they seem to I wouldn't I
would not vote for any of these
positions
further comments represents Sweden yeah
thank you representative cameras for
jogging me I remember I think in one
column they had the average of each
month versus the actual for the last
year and that kind of made the the chart
didn't make sense so I do recall what
you're referencing all right let's
representative Griffin I'll just add
that I had a constituent who had a
problem
and uh
his problem became my problem I had
great difficulty getting a hold of them
and getting satisfactory and
representative evil I mean that that
could be a staffing issue I don't know
they seemed like they were really
strained but these are also large
numbers so
I'm
if the division prefers not to fund it
right
okay it seems a consensus that we will
not uh go with these extra priorities
Mr chair I'm sorry to go back to the
child advocate but I did have a question
on this where it says case management
system two hundred thousand dollars and
then for fiscal 2024 it shows 700 are
they planning on spending it in 2020
I just wondered because 700 is a really
low number that's probably just the
maintenance of that system is that
yeah that's
yeah it is
um
go ahead no I was just gonna well
they're looking but I'd hate
I think they have just an unbelievable
responsibility and they have all these
issues and if giving them a little more
money for their
case management system would help them I
still I don't know so I just wanted to
go back to that and understand the
spending
well I put a yes Melissa
just reading their notes really quickly
and I think they got most of the
spending already in 2022 to implement
this and this was just the last bit that
they needed to finish off their system
but it's a 200 000 or is it 700 it's 200
000 with the last bit I mean 500 000 in
the next uh in fiscal year 2025.
of 700 in 20 25 minutes correct I I
don't promise
all right so we'll but listen to Mr
chairman so they've got a system which
they've been working on and spending
money on but they haven't completed and
if we don't fund it it's going to be
sitting there uncompleted
yeah that doesn't make sense right
Melissa or Mike could you recall
I'm looking at their handout and
they talk about the system improvements
will allow for better ability to track
state agency child and child serving
agencies compliance with contracts laws
policies procedures without this
enhancement the office will have delayed
or insufficient data capture
and less timely investigations related
directly to Children's current safety
and well-being
the office will also have decreased
capacity measure outcomes provide timely
relevant recommendations for system
support and reform
so I guess my concern hearing that is if
it's so important why wasn't it Priority
number one
representative Griffin and I fall back
on why didn't the governor put it in the
budget if it was so important if it was
a half done project or something
all right well we'll continue to move on
and if you get any more information
Melissa and Mike on that or I'm sure
people are watching you might hear
something more but
I think so
next we have
the department of Information Technology
and again this is uh
all other funds but they're not really
other funds because they come from
either general or federal or other other
funds
so any thoughts um
we heard all these representative
McGuire yeah I kind of like one through
five in this category
um and especially three and four so the
liquor ones
those
those seem seemed very important right
because
um they're they're starting
they're completely redoing their
um system and this these two uh
positions lets them
hire fewer Consultants right so so if we
don't put these in they're going to be
spending on Consultants who are even
more expensive
from the from the uh this next-gen
company whereas putting in these two
positions lets them take over from the
Consultants quicker so to me that these
are three and four are smart and if
three and four are good well then one
and two presumably these are about
privacy right I mean that's an important
aspect of
um
I.T right so I I think
and then number five if I remember right
is a similar thing as the liquor ones
right with it they're
um they again remember that this is the
one where they're spending four hundred
dollars an hour or something to get
support and if they can do the support
in-house it's going to be much cheaper
so so we so I like one through five I
guess so we all could one through five
representative Griffin
so I have a question
where's the other side of these numbers
are they already in the budget or we
have to add them to the budget or
they're they're all in the budget
somewhere else like the one we had Board
of tax and land appeals where they had
the nineteen thousand General going to
doit so somewhere probably in here
there's going to be a reference to the
board of tax and land appeals so these
are in the budget somewhere else and the
next one you'll see is safety I don't
think we should act on that until we
know what division two is done but
they're elsewhere in the budget is a
spent
so it could be general for instance the
Department of Revenue Administration I
would assume that's General funds
because that's where they get them
already
because it's the department of
it's
d-o-i-t-o-i-t so they're getting it from
some other they're getting it from
revenue so if we go into this book
they're somewhere there is that right Mr
Hoffman
just to clarify if you approve these
we would add them in doat's budget and
we go to the sending agency and add them
there
yeah
the liquor Position will be a charge to
liquor fund but show up in this doat
budget as other funds yeah
so liquor is all liquor but the
Department of Revenue is all General so
somewhere there'd be a line for General
to support this yeah so we we're
actually increasing so we're going to
increase this right
well seven was another rims related
position
all right representative McGuire you
want to yeah so but but we're giving
them part part there I guess right
yeah
new position to support the next phase
of rams and seven
so again it's
so it's very clear if we approve this
it's got to be paid for
by probably in this particular case
General funds because it's coming out of
Revenue
except for three and four which is
liquor which are liquor funds
hopefully
well it says on each one right number
one and number two are forty percent
General funds yeah
all right so one through five
one through five
so okay so just going back though the
hb2 request number one there I don't
mean the money one I mean the doit thing
we didn't actually decide on this right
I thought we had but I'm not sure I
thought I remember we talked about it in
negative terms but I don't know whether
we actually decided on it that's the one
without their priority on the top it
doesn't have a number
the information Technology Council any
I I have I have thoughts
um I'm on the I'm on the I.T Council and
I know that the commissioner
wants more legislative representation
but on the other side of that I know
that the speaker is really concerned
about the ballooning of of these
commissions and increasing legislative
uh time commitments that they can't
fulfill so I personally
um would not recommend this I think it
should be fine the way it is
all right so you're suggesting leaving
it as two Representatives
any more thoughts on that we okay with
that okay so we're we will not support
that request
s
[Laughter]
the one without a priority one without a
presence so
much question
I just have a question so for the
positions one and two it says 40 General
funds so would it be forty percent of
that number or is that the or is that
the number
those two positions they charge all
other state agencies so it's allocated
and what we probably do to implement
that is put together a uh section in
House Bill 2 and get the funding detail
from the Department
okay thank you so that would make me
inclined to say yes on those two if it's
only 40 from General yep
okay and again we'll get a sheet similar
to this represent a camera as it will
look just like this and it'll have all
the numbers like the corresponding
transfers
and it's why they'd hope we have
everything done by tomorrow so they can
work the rest of the week and have
everything prepared for next week for us
to present to full Finance
so skipping down I guess to seven
again that's all General funds that we
were okay with that I think
eight priority eight is Department of
Safety we should probably wait to hear
from division two
nine is uh division two that's Fish and
Game
then we have the
Department of administrative service and
Department of Justice
Melissa Mr K I mean Mr Hoffman can you
recall
this particular request
we're at the bottom of page two is that
what's your
num it's marked as priority 11 whether I
guess
oh priority 11. I'm just like that would
be a shared
um
person
that would be probably General funds
because of those two apartments are
mostly mostly General funds but it would
one person will be shared for I.T
support between administrative services
and justice
thoughts again both of those agencies
are primarily funded with General funds
so that would be a general fund impact
I tend to think we should skip these
lower priority things especially because
you know it has trouble enough hiring
you know you you dump us a huge number
of positions on them they already have
open positions
doesn't doesn't seem to gain much
sounds fair we okay with that
so 11 priority marked 11 that will be
off Melissa and like then we go jump
down to uh
liquor
again these would be all liquor funds
most likely and that's not guaranteed
because sometimes the liquor does get
General funds it's not a lot but
any issues with
both those two items uh Liquor
Commission
I mean obviously they're needed but I I
would have liked to seen the note on
there that says that it would be liquor
functions yeah because that makes the
most sense and they're self you know
self uh funded so yes these will both be
liquor funds
all right we okay then with that
then the next three with the Department
of Information Technology on page three
those are liquor
uh commission again Mr Hoffman or
Melissa are we pretty confident those
are all liquor funds yes okay so we okay
with four through six
judicial Council
as you probably that's uh there's no
priority there but four million dollars
as you know that the judicial Council
can come to
fiscal for additional help if necessary
it's a
probably a terrible thing to do but
oftentimes in the budget we don't
completely fund this we because we know
they can go to physical but Mr Hoffman
or Melissa any comments
they had a proposal in their agency
request to the governor for a secondary
public defender program
and that was not included in the
governor's budget so they described it
when they were in for their presentation
okay representative Sweeney
thank you for sure I would just say with
their unique ability to go to fiscal to
get the funding if needed I I would be
uh I don't want to put this in the
budget
is my field four million in general
funds is a is a big price tag when not
all the other agencies have the same
ability to go to fiscal if needed
yeah sure so when the judicial Council
goes to fiscal do they get the money
they need
just the ability to go doesn't I don't
think in life
several terms they've ever been denied
but they do have to make a request that
has to be approved and this is generally
for outside counsel and
yes representative Weiler nice to see
you sir see you since they don't know at
the beginning of how many cases they're
going to have and they hire the lawyers
as needed so they they start out with
very little money in their budget then
they come to fiscal on a regular basis
it's not a not a lot of money that we
don't have something to spare but the
idea is they they really start off with
a big big amount of money and then they
come to fiscal after they see what the
number of cases they'll have to deal
with
thank you yeah as I recall there's
already something like a 10 million
dollar increase from the previous
biennium in this particular area it's
substantial it's very substantial but
the one thing you know now that we're
talking about this particular budget
they had kind of three categories of
attorneys there was the kind that are
employees there's the kind that are have
contracts and then there's the kind that
are hired
just on a for a particular case right
and it seemed to me that the contract
ones were the most cost effective and
and if it was me I would but they're
having trouble finding them because
their cost effective right and so I
would move money into the contract area
maybe from the the one-time area and and
have them raise rates that they offer
for contracts to maybe attract more
people into the contract area so that
was how I was gonna propose we changed
that particular area of the budget move
some into the contract area but you know
I don't know if there's time or whatever
to do that and as representative
Wireless said they can come to fiscal
should they get in a jam
not that that's great budgeting but
that's what we've done
okay
um
so we'll remove the four million dollars
from that request
so we had a presentation by the
Department of Justice and I recalled was
wasn't there something other than the
witness specialist program position
something to do with elderly
Easter they had two requests one for the
witness Specialists and then a
transportation attorney that would be
funded by do
T I almost said I thought there was
something else but anyway
all right thoughts on those two items
representative evil no I was just going
to say on the victim I think it it was
the elderly who were the victim victims
yeah they said that there had they had
seen a great increase in the scamming
attempts on the elderly and they really
thought that they needed more help with
that
okay
to me it seems like a reasonable request
especially since they identify the
problem with the elderly
being taken advantage of thoughts
okay with checking those both of those
off Transportation dot which would
probably be
federal funds dot as far as that
line of funding Highway funds
then we move down to liquor that there's
no particular priority
it's all other is that all liquor funds
it should be Mr Hoffman Melissa
yes that'll be liquor funds
Annie represent Maguire so these are the
matching ones for the previous numbers
you see how the numbers are the same
for the other thing is that we so we
sort of already approved these yeah oh
okay it's just a dip coming in
all right so we'll check off all those
liquor items
oh this could be a good place the next
one office of professional licensure
we could jump to your Amendment
representative of wire and close
something out on a good note
you want to offer that now as as far as
oplc yeah well notice that these are
savings right so yeah so they certainly
seem like a good idea
well I don't know if if we don't go with
all those sections whether this actually
is oh I see yeah that's a good question
they had some positions in the hospital
one that were previously full-time
temporary positions that were converted
to full time
so they had the funds budget in two
places
in case the full-time conversions were
not approved when they came in they
identified this and said if we
if we're successful getting full-time
positions we can reduce this money from
our budget
you know whether like six or something
yeah five or six five or six yeah
all right so is that okay yeah it's okay
but it notice it's all other because
they're now off budgets right right yeah
so I guess we can say
okay for that but just because we're
like near that office of professional
licensure I thought you'd like to maybe
jump with but I mean we're all we're
going to talk about this
uh so just moving down
Department of Revenue
we had a lot of discussion on that Rim
it's not sure again well this is again
yeah these are matching yeah these are
magically so we're good with those
or just do whatever a lot of money
the last row is the Consultants you know
that I don't think you've acted on that
what's that the last one the last row on
page three
yeah we didn't talk
oh those others
should we do two out of three
it's expensive
yeah it's all
it's all General funds
we give them one give them one yeah for
the consultant yeah
one additional consultant Melissa Mike
so however that breaks down that eight
hundred thousand and one point three
million
and again that's General funds that's a
significant
ask
that would
representative Hewitt that that wouldn't
uh have anything to do with the rims
that we improved the equipment
what
yeah yeah it would
it's a maintenance
I believe represented I mean I'm sorry
Melissa and Mike any Bots
we'd have to go back and look at their
uh presentation but I believe the
commissioner said that uh they use these
Consultants with the rim system and they
hope to
bring their own staff up to speed but
they need them for
in in the interim period
seems to be coming back yeah I mean
that's my recollection as well they
really wanted to get their own people
but in the meantime they had to use the
Consultants
very expensive hopefully the one
consultant can help bring the people up
to where they should be
hmm
commissioner you're still here what are
you here for
oh well tomorrow represent Maguire when
I guess would like to hold his Amendment
until tomorrow I think very likely
um no change no it'll come out of the
budget
the foresterlights if that's what you're
asked yeah
so you got everybody on edge now so I
might as well go break the news you know
so
the division will be looking at an
amendment that's offered by
representative McGuire you know
apparently a lot of you are sitting here
waiting for no
all sections will be removed
and then the division will go back and
look at an amendment that was offered on
Friday for 6.55
and include that perhaps but I think
that was yeah pretty much the unanimous
foot
um as far as the Edna committee and
those of us listening
but then we're going to go back and look
at some of the others there were
recommendations by the Secretary of
State's office to move three I believe
agencies there
and there's a couple others like Hawker
and Peddlers I think representative
cabrals was interested in seeing that
removed
all right as far as a requirement but
all the others that have generated a
great deal of angst
will probably be left out but that's not
to say that someone may want to see
something brought in but I think
representative McGuire and you know
worked very hard over the weekend with
the chair of the committee or the chair
of the Edna committee yeah and we spoke
and I think some good suggestions coming
on it we've listened to you know the
folks that have reached out to us and
I'm so when we're not gonna
we really can't take any questions but
you'll have to remind me 285 was pardon
yeah I'm gonna change that yeah that I
think that remains out but again I I'm
not going to speak the division is going
to discuss this but just to let you know
we're taking everything out we're going
to go back and look at the specific
pieces but where there's no controversy
I think will be okay but we've heard
from you know hundreds of people over
the weekend thank you Governor sanuno
but anyway
pardon yeah it'll be yeah it'll be
pretty small it will you know be very
small it changes that we put it back the
things we put back it'll it'll be a
that's 20 of the pages or something
so the division heard loud and clear
that there were some concerns we I think
I can say all of us agree that there
needs to be more participation by those
affected before it moves forward
so but thanks for hanging around I guess
now you
uh I was a concern when I saw the
Timberland owner there sitting back
there what trouble we were in again but
yeah that's what I I know he carries a
big ax
thanks
all right one more time so I want to
thank representative McGuire for all his
work and over the weekend and yes thank
you so much done a lot of listening and
I appreciate that
so going to the last page page four the
Department of Revenue Administration
replacing aging cars we okay with that
what's the condition of the ones you're
driving now
you're aging I'm not sure how old they
are but they're aging yeah
yeah I mean again the government they
did make a
it didn't like as representative McGuire
just said the governor didn't include it
in his budget but the commissioner
didn't make a case that
um maybe we can cut it down a little
better
yeah I mean I would say we all try to
hold on to our vehicles 15 to 20 years
now so I don't know how old theirs are
but
so we looked maybe 75
000 or if it was it
that's fine with that yeah as long as
they don't buy EVS I'd only buy them one
so all right
classic cars they could probably
probably buy two with that but that's a
start
so Melissa Mr Hoffman 75
35 for each year yeah
uh temporary staffing 20 000 we heard
like Commissioners say that during the
busy season they really need people to
open envelopes and that sort of thing so
how about for fiscal year 24 only
because when we get rid of the interest
and dividends taxes there'll be much
fewer envelopes
yes
you're as tight
[Laughter]
I often said
I've often said to representative
Maguire's as tight as bark on a tree so
anyway
okay so are we okay with the 20 000
representative of life okay
I think we have to do the next one
so treasury doit funds of
yeah okay so that's okay yeah it was
removed by mistake
and then was this next one just a
textural change
yeah
Mr Hoffman Treasurer came in and asked
for this debt service line to be moved
to Department of Revenue and uh
the Commission of Revenue came in and
said they don't agree with it but after
that they have had a meeting and they
agreed with the move as long as they can
have the um
I'll spill two language listed here
added
all right we okay with that
so it being 11 30 I'll run over and see
if Janet's got the list ready for the
exact session and we can talk about that
quickly yeah
and we should realize that we just spent
what another
three million yeah six maybe between the
two years right you know so it's got to
come from somewhere
so we won't repeal either
taxes that proposal adds money it
doesn't suppress
oh okay
oh there
oh the public relations
oh okay good all right
yeah I think so but do we have to um
House Bill 250
yeah let's do that
so House Bill 250 has to be exact this
afternoon so I think we should talk
about it now since we sort of left it
hanging
full Finance so but we should give them
a recommendation right yeah
like Finance was the division one show
yeah right it is yeah
yeah I won't get any lunch
I'm gonna get ready for that
good
yeah
all right
so House Bill 250 if you recall this is
the one about accidental death benefits
and when we looked into it we discovered
that so this was to raise it from 50 to
100 percent
but and only for group twos originally
and but what we discovered is of the 19
we'll just say widows who are getting
benefits right now
because of the way the calculation is
done there are two of them that are
currently getting about 125 000 a year
so so if we change it to a hundred those
would have been 250 000. now now the
bill itself will not affect anyone
currently getting benefits right because
because the way the retirement system
works as soon as your your benefits are
set as soon as you retire that's it
unless there are colas but but but
future changes in methods of calculating
only affect future people they don't
affect past right so so
and then the second thing about the bill
was it seemed a little bit unfair to be
only group two when it's possible for
group one people especially in D.O.T to
to be killed on the job right you know
so uh so so my proposal is as follows so
um have it apply both to group one and
group two chain keep the hundred percent
um but put a cap
right of 85 000 on the total payment
now the reason 85 000 I thought a
hundred thousand would be a reasonable
cap and this money is not taxable
so so a hundred thousand
with taxes is something like 85 000
without taxes so so that's that
and the other change here though
is no is that
originally group two is earnable
compensation
and not average final compensation
there's a weird difference between what
group ones our average final
compensation and group twos are earnable
compensation and and it seemed like
average final compensation is the right
thing to use because that will
that
it makes it more like regular salary
sort of and a little less like
um something
out of bounds
okay so the the average final
compensation means that five-year
average of your five highest uh years
rather than exactly what you got this
last year sort of thing so so I think
this is a very reasonable
um
uh Amendment it does do the basics which
is change fifty percent to a hundred
percent but it but it has some caps and
it has some you know other thing to make
it make it more reasonable so
that's
what oh and and so I would move
um I guess ought to pass with Amendment
on this because this this doesn't affect
the current budget
unless in case you know someone someone
is killed during this season you know
they it would affect them but but it but
there's no
there's no fiscal note in that that
sense
I I would just say as the as the member
that was going to move to retain 250
this afternoon I'm happy to pass it on
to you to amend it
oh I would suck in the motion to adopt
this ogpa
yes all right show of hands on the
amendment
yeah but I wasn't here so oh okay so I
guess uh seven to zero and then ought to
pass with Amendment the clerk want to
take a take a vote here
okay
otpa
um moved so I'm gonna have it moved by
McGuire could somebody second his okay
cambrose
okay representative McGuire
yes representative Griffin
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camberells yes
um representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
clerk votes yes chair Leachman and I
wasn't here so okay so you'll okay okay
so one two three four five
five seven seven zero
unanimous
otpa now we can go to finance
foreign
74.
that is
the ambrell's moved itl five to three
that looks correct
um I had an idea about this one actually
um this one and 234
so
234 I guess we could for neither one of
these had a fiscal note right neither
one really we decided that there's
anything
about Finance here it's just a matter of
sending it back and having another vote
on it right yeah and
um so I was thinking we should send them
back without recommendation
rather than
with some like this one it's itl just
because five of us don't like it and
three of us do right but but we could
actually send it back to the floor
without recommendation and the way we
can do that is in the big room if we
propose itl and vote it down and we
propose OTP and vote it down then
there's no recommendation right so
that's that's what I'm thinking is right
with 74 and 234. I I would agree with
that I mean having written the committee
report for 234 the bottom line was there
was no fiscal effect and um you know I
don't see why we can't go in you just
say there's no recommendation and that
the because that maybe supports us but
it's not a vote you can't vote on no
recommendations yeah
yeah so anyways
yeah we can make a
OTP itl and just say I recommend you
vote no on this you know it sounds like
can you change that since we've already
taken a vote can you no can you just
take yeah I will make or you will make
because it could go to the floor and say
that the financing like in your report
is no Financial impact and
Let It Go with that but to have like two
votes like and then hope it's a we can't
really have a tie because we've got 25
but they could be IDL loses and OTP
moves
exactly it just looks kind of
yes right well my opinion is that yeah
granted they didn't have fiscal notes
but they came here we took the time on
this and we took the time to to take a
vote on it and if sometimes they stick
us for policy issues we're still a
subcommittee and I believe it's our job
to make recommendations where where at
all possible so I agree with
representative cambrell say because we
did discuss it and
in
I represented Campbell's blur but I
think it was pretty clear on
74.
but
I just think it makes it kind of
complicated to go out and have a vote
everybody votes no and then everyone
votes yes and we can say in the blurb
there was no Financial impact like you
both said
on General funding finances
I just don't want to complicate things
think
so in 212 it's a e-fas
were you gonna have something well yeah
we we do
we remember I forwarded to you uh rep
yes we have a house bill 2 Amendment
right with that and it uh do we have it
back took the cost out and used it right
I can explain it we don't have the text
yeah I have the text I didn't know if
you wanted to get that out or just work
on these bills because that's really a
houseboat too yeah so this is a retain
it's going to be a house bill too I can
just explain
about here
here money the request request was two
million dollars what
um what the amendment is is that they uh
they just say that up to ten percent of
the fund can be used for investigation
and and there were textural changes to
the use of the fund
so they did what we asked them I mean
what we discussed
all right so um
2 30 we actually kind of went over that
a little while ago as far as the money
that went to agriculture that's in hb2
234 this is where your no recommendation
will come in representative McGuire
right but we have an odd number so oh I
know so the only way to have no
recommendation is if somebody said for
everybody to vote no on everything yeah
exactly so that's what I plan to do
all right well so 250 while I was out
you took that up and that you'll speak
to that representative McGuire yes and
the vote was six to zero seven
oh that's right Wyler was here right
right representative Weiler
okay 272 is
um
yeah
but he didn't wait I'm just our chair
didn't well I didn't vote yeah three
yeah seven zero seven is seven right you
do good
he's a numbers guy
yeah
so uh the next one is division two
um
let's see
cyanobacteria yeah
because we need to study that's a real
real retain with a capital R okay
food away sets going into the budget
right representative in that vote
apparently was unanimous there
seven zero
two six one Well Carrie recalls it was
unanimous but if I did a triple back
flip you probably didn't see me
National Guard recruiting are you rep
represent why are you all set with this
okay
we'll assume yeah
so licensure
337.
that was just like a notice oh yeah
notice of hearings yeah it was a minor
thing yeah so you're all set with that
representative McGuire I think I still
have to write yeah
nothing he's he's actually got them all
done he's really good about them I don't
think I do I don't think you have this
one though but anyway retain on the next
one that was in the morning yeah
okay the tenants
that was again unnoticed it was just a
notice yeah that could go on
Solid Waste Management this is in the
budget
representative evil you're good
yeah you'll speak to that
Adult Parole Board representative Hewitt
you're all set with this speak
all right
uh Chief Information officer that I
think this was just Edward's Bill you'll
I'll sit with this representative
McGuire did this one did we put it in
House Bill too or not
you'll have to remind us Mr Hoffman it
sounds similar to the language in House
Bill too but this one had no cost and
this just aligned with
um
their current practices so it brings the
definitions into align with what they
have the one in the other one in
hospital 2 is privacy so we've got
security and privacy so we're not
affecting the same line two different
things okay nice okay all right so this
is Scandal yeah this is very exciting
this one uh represents McGuire this was
this was okay
um
representative Sweeney we've got you
down the next one that was you worked
with representative manager Puti and the
banking people
all right I think we're good
so
because Janet sent the notice for our
work session tomorrow did not make it in
the calendar
I have to say that we're going to
reconvene tomorrow at 9 30 right now so
we are reconvening our work session for
tomorrow at 9 30 at which time will take
up all the oplc
and the retirement bills that we're
still waiting for some information on
and other than that we're pretty close
to
done and appreciate everyone's efforts
we'll have all new sheets tomorrow
morning as well as far as everything
that's been shaded out
and I would just like to
again thank you all there's a lot going
on here
I think we've made some good progress
and again I would Echo what
representative Sweeney said is trying to
get together on a couple of things which
we may still be a little distant on
all right so we're in full committee for
exec session and all these bills at one
o'clock
go team
oh we could do that
oh there we go so we get some more
information on that okay that's this one
oh yeah this here we go now we gotta
read
thanks Mike and Melissa for getting us
this
hundred thousand in the and the I mean
we have more information here I mean PR
doesn't really have a great connotation
in some ways but it really is like
sharing information about the about what
they do and trying to get the word out
to affected people it's less expensive
than case management so I mean I don't
know
it is their top priority
so representative Sweeney thank you Mr I
would say the for it might not be their
top priority but for me I'd rather spend
money on the case management software
and the hopes that that would make it
more efficient in the future for their
staff time
I'm a
I'm a hard no on the public relations
representative
um as an additional request but I would
support the the software
it representative Sweeney is supporting
the software anyone like to second that
representative Griffin is there any more
discussion on that the 200 000 request
seeing nine will just have a show of
hands if that works
all right unanimous
well don't push your luck
all right
all right so again we'll reconvene at 9
30 tomorrow morning right here
okay
you have anything else for us that we
need to just any questions
oh